what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so after reading the free comic
book day release of secret Empire I can
almost guarantee you guys there's going
to be so much backlash and there's going
to be a lot of resurgence in this
argument that Hydra is the same thing as
the Nazis and so I've been I've been
seeing this argument a lot of people
been asking me to address it but I've
been seeing this argument a lot and
there's a lot of different kind of book
news companies that have basically been
sort of peddling misinformation and so
what we're going to do is we are going
to rectify that and were actually gonna
cite sources we're going to reference
what it is we're talking about so you
guys have an idea what we're coming from
and what things are about so to give
ourselves a baseline here we're going to
sort of run over the Nazis in Marvel
Comics now the Nazis in Marvel are
exactly what you would expect them to be
but the issue is that their history is
kind of waxing waned over the years the
most recent indication of what the Nazi
Party was about really came with Ed
Brubaker's run of Captain America at
least that was the most in-depth
explanation about the Nazis it for the
most part the Nazis are exactly what we
think they are I mean they were
basically a political party that's based
out of Germany rose to prominence in the
anti-semitic nature of Germany at the
time following the signing of the Treaty
of Versailles and the near collapse of
the other country in terms of its
economy and in the result was that it
intended to initiate a nationwide and
eventual worldwide police state all the
while suspending things like freedom of
speech and freedom of the press and
freedom of assembly and so on and so
forth basically a fascist state as we
tend to think of it now in terms of
Hydra because that's really all there is
about the Nazis I mean you have like
Adolf Hitler who is running the show you
have the Red Skull who is a
second-in-command and you had a few
people here and there like like Baron
Strucker
but Baron von Strucker action will be a
little bit more prominent here in a
second the idea of Hydra base all the
way back to the earliest days of
humanity now we're not giving a whole
lot of information here we're really
really given a timeline and secret
warriors number two by Brian Michael
Bendis and Jonathan Hickman but what we
know is that somewhere along the line
there was a cabal that basically arrived
on earth for the purpose of creating an
evil Society in and of itself and at the
time at least as was established in in
Wolverine vol 3 issue number 29 I think
this cabal had basically corrupted a
group called the Brotherhood of the
sphere now the Brotherhood of the sphere
was basically the earliest versions of
the group that we call the hand and the
idea was the Brotherhood of the sphere
had basically broken off from
traditional Japanese society and sought
to basically have their own society that
focus on samurai codes and different
things
that but the idea here is that what the
Brotherhood of the spear having been
corrupted it created a civil war within
the spear that ultimately led to the
formation of the hand as we know it as
so the result was at the hand basically
defeated those corrupted members of the
Brotherhood of the spear and then
withdrew and basically became this very
amid not expect operating out of Japan
that delves in mysticism and
resurrecting the dead and so on and so
forth now because of the fact that Hydra
as it existed at that point in time was
basically eliminated in World War two
Hydra was reconstituted but Hydra was
reformed to be the antithesis to the
Germans and so far as they sought world
domination but considered the Germans to
have been nonsensical and how they did
it originally the idea was that Baron
von Strucker operating as one of the
commanders of Adolf Hitler had
consistently been met with defeat after
the defeat at the hand of the invaders
so Captain America Bucky Barnes the
original Human Torch Jim Hammond and
named when the Submariner because of the
fact that Baron von Strucker had been
defeated time and time again Adolf
Hitler basically ordered the death of
they're in von Strucker of course that
was covered and Wolverine Origins issues
19 and 20 the result is that in this
same story Red Skull basically smuggled
Baron von Strucker out of Germany and
then Baron von Strucker travelled to
Japan killed the existing leader of
Hydra and took his place and so
following this and secret warriors
issues one and two Hickman and Brian
Michael Bendis basically established
that over the course of hydras existence
as it then restructured by Baron von
Strucker Hydra had sought the same goal
of a world domination that the Nazi
Party did the difference here is that
when Hydra looked at the Nazis he said
well the Nazis wanted to eliminate
everybody who was against it the perfect
German but of what use is world
domination if everybody that you have
domain over is dead and so because of
that Hydra began to basically intertwine
itself in all facets of society now of
course this was given to us by way of
this this kind of cool back up feature
you know that was designed by Hickman
and Bendis to show us the four different
sects that Hydra was involved in the
first were their basic like more or less
sub city or subsidiary organizations
groups that are closely intertwined with
Hydra and have basically adopt the name
of Hydra but exist in three forms the
first is the secret Empire the second is
then and the third is aim now them was
basically like the inner circle
of Hydra it was more or less Baron von
strucker's own personal group that he
would basically use in order to dictate
the actions of most everybody else in
Hydra and the different organization so
kind of think of it like the inner
circle of Hydra so to speak that
immediately surrounded von Strucker the
secret Empire was an organization
designed to draw attention away from
Hydra itself and so the idea here was
that where Hydra was immersed in a
multitude of different activities secret
Empire would basically engage in all
these crazy little aspects and these
crazy little actions and they would
exist for the purpose of basically
making a whole bunch of noise and
getting the authorities to look at them
now of course a secret Empire itself at
least in terms of the organization for
the first made its debut in tales to
astonish number 81 in 1966 so we're not
referencing the secret Empire as it
exists now by Nick Spencer that's
basically just a recreation of what was
already there and a reformation at the
hands of Captain America of the
organization the way it originally
existed now advanced idea mechanics is
basically the technological arm of Hydra
this is the group that made the first
cosmic cube that appeared in Marvel
Comics we never see their faces they
only wear those yellow suits they're
basically the scientists they're the
organization that's routinely tried to
take over the world now of course for
those of you guys who were reading
all-new all-different marvel right now
advanced idea mechanics was basically
bought out by robert decosta and turned
into a superhero team more or less I
mean it was basically co-opted now of
course the reason for that is because of
the fact that aim and as well as them
and secret Empire it all basically
vacated the Hydra landscape following
the death of Baron von Strucker they
basically achieved their own
independence and they started engaging
in their own goals or their goals were
still for the most part the same as
Hydra in the sense that they sought
world domination and the elimination of
all different ideologies in terms of
freedom and political assembly and
different things like that now in
addition to these various subsidiary
organizations Hydra also involved itself
in international corporation so there's
typhoon and there's a kidnap or there's
also a multitude of others but this
serve the purpose of allowing Hydra to
basically be involved in the economic
landscape across the world they could
essentially money-launderer they could
spend their money on different things
without anybody asking any questions of
what it was that they were involved in
in addition to this Hydra also began
involving itself in different
governmental assets so the US government
the Department of Treasury different
things like that the Canadian government
the Russian government now all these
thing
basically stemmed out and it allowed
hydra to control different laws that
were being passed and different bills
they were being proposed to Congress and
to the different ruling bodies or I
guess the political bodies lawmaking
bodies in terms of these different on
different countries but the biggest
achievement of Hydra was basically
creating shield and this was established
again like all this other stuff and
secret warriors issues 1 & 2 with
regards to secret warriors what Bendis
and Hickman basically established here
was at an order for Hydra to be able to
operate without anybody knowing what it
is that they're doing that they
essentially went in and they had their
own puppet people inside the United
Nations so there are basically members
of the United Nations who were working
for Hydra at the time in the 1960s when
shield was first formed it was formed at
the behest of those Hydra agents working
in the United Nations and what it would
do is it would allow Hydra to send
shield on a multitude of campaigns what
they would do things like defeat
advanced idea mechanics they would
defeat them they would defeat secret
empire time and time again and what this
would basically be looked at by shield
as achievements in continuing to take
down the role of Hydra all the while
never realizing that they were
controlled by Hydra themselves and so
again it was a really great ruse it was
a really great way to basically keep the
various organizations and intelligence
agencies of the world under control now
of course the reason why this is
significant is because of the fact that
in the realm of Marvel Comics there are
a multitude of organizations that sought
world domination and look to implement
the same policies that we would consider
to be Ignasi policies and that's the
issue fascism is not inherent to the
Nazis it's not strictly a Nazi concept
in the realm of Marvel Comics there's
been historically like there's been a
ton of different organizations and even
villains that have sought to conquer the
world and implement fascist policies for
example apocalypse Norman Osborn when he
was director of shield Ultron onslaught
a nihilist tried to conquer the universe
Dormammu routinely tries to invade the
main Marvel Universe in terms of
organizations he got the Hellfire Club
children of the ball sons of a serpent
there are a ton of different groups
across Marvel Comics that serve the
purpose of trying to conquer the world
and implement things like restricting
freedom of assembly or restricting
people's ability to speak publicly
freedom of speech different things like
that so again it's not strictly a Nazi
thing to say that Hydra as an
organization is the same as the Nazis
because there are people who were Nazis
inform Hydra is like saying that because
Michael Jordan left
skeeball to go play baseball did
basketball and baseball are the same
thing not by any stretch of the
imagination so anyway guys I want to go
ahead and just kind of get this video
out there speak some truth to the
misinformation but if you guys are new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob port if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]